the next query really is regarding a
woman who is pregnant or is nursing
breastfeeding nursing rearing the
children why they
Exempted according to the words of the
Quran in Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number 185 that if a person is ill
and traveling he can make up his
prescribed periods of day of fasting
later on so most of the FAS most of the
scholars they say that these women who
are pregnant and breastfeeding they come
under the category of those who are ill
so therefore if they want they can
abstain from fasting but there are
clearcut say in which the prophet has
Exempted these women from fasting
mention
in
MA Hadith number 1667 that our beloved
Prophet says the obligation for a person
to fast and part of the prayer to have
been lifted from a traveler and the
obligation for fasting has been lifted
from a lady who's pregnant and with best
feeding our beloved Prophet mam also
said it's mentioned
in in the book of fasting Hadi number 2
to 74 that Allah subhana tala has
relieved The Traveler from fasting and
half his prayer and Allah subhah wa
ta'ala has relieved the pregnant woman
and the woman who's breastfeeding from
fasting So based on these two Hadith
also so it's clearcut that the pregnant
women and the women who are best feeding
they have been Exempted and The Logical
reason that one can think is because
when a lady she's pregnant or she's
breastfeeding the food she eats is not
only for herself it's for herself as
well as the baby she's carrying or
become difficult for a baby then she's
Exempted from fasting but if she's in
the early stage of pregnancy and if she
feels or she's breastfeeding and if she
feels that fasting will not cause any
damage to her health and will not cause
a damage to the baby then she should
fast if she has a doubt if she can do it
with hardship as long as there's no
damage to herself to her health and the
baby she has option to fast not to fast
but if it's causing damage to her health
or the baby it becomes Haram for her to
fast because Allah subhana wa taala does
not want to lay a burden more than what
a person can bear and in this God that
is the reason Allah has Exempted them
later on when they healthy and they stop
breastfeeding or when the pregnancy ends
after post Nal bleeding then they have
to make up for the fast they have
missed
e
e for